tres olivos en una plaza de dunn y en el
norte de parís simbolizan que la ciudad
está comprometida con la paz es una
iniciativa de michelle del plan
habitante de la comuna que perdió su
hija elsa ya su ex esposa la chilena
patricia san martín hace cinco años en
el atentado del bataclán michelle lucha
cada día porque la paz les gane la
batalla al oscurantismo no estamos en
una guerra de religión unir una amalgama
entre una creencia religiosa legítima
como el islam y la locura asesina de un
individuo fanatizado no puede ser
tolerada es por torera con esta carta
participó en su comuna del homenaje
nacional a samuel para ti el profesor
decapitado por un terrorista este tipo
de noticias vuelven abrigo en el heridas
profundas con ondas de que se ven cuando
ocurren cosas como la que acaba de pasar
con el atentado contra el profesor
samuel para ti
el atentado de estrasburgo o bien todo
vuelve
el terrorismo aún es virulento cinco
años han pasado sí pero todas las
imágenes están ahí todos los
sentimientos fuertes están allí último
la paz también está en el título del
libro que hace dos años publicó ramón
gonzález un español que sobrevivió a la
tragedia del mata clan junto a su novio
una argentina y varios amigos el libro
comenzó como una terapia y terminó dando
un giro a su vida ramón dejó su trabajo
informático y hoy enseña español y está
preparando su segunda novela a todos los
niveles no sólo a nivel de describir el
atentado significo
bueno hacer lo que lo que yo quería
hacer sin sin demora un proceso
importante de terapia y además con el
libro pues ayudó mucho a sacar cosas
entonces en mi caso si se ha podido
olvidar y aunque tratan de dejarlo atrás
es inevitable
para los sobrevivientes cada atentado es
una prueba al igual que cada nuevo 13 de
noviembre en el calendario